les années 90 deux hommes ont réussi une
des plus grosses escroqueries de
l'industrie de la musique
énorme scandale il s'agit du duo milli
vanilli l'histoire incroyable de ces
deux danseurs qui ont réussi à faire
croire qu'ils étaient chanteurs allant
même jusqu'à remporter un grammy awards
mais il est vénéré
[Applaudissements]
la brice morvent europe pilatus deux
jeunes hommes respectivement français et
allemands un duo qui cartonne au début
des années 90 avec girl you know exclu
vous pourrez ramener au label 250
millions de dollars soit environ 10
millions dans leur poche et ce titre a
été vendu à 10 millions d'exemplaires
soit cette fois disque de platine
une chanson dont ils sont censés être
les interprètes originaux sauf que voilà
ils n'ont jamais chanté car tout a été
créé par leurs producteurs
il s'est identifié à cette voie
rapidement des journalistes finissent
par découvrir le pot-aux-roses et a
révélé la supercherie
une découverte que le duo à un thonier
avant de reconnaître les faits d'un jour
à l'autre on a perdu château l'avenir
pour l'un d'entre eux roh pilatus est
bien plus sombre puisqu'il tombera dans
la drogue et la délinquance avant de
mettre fin à ses jours
mais fabrice morvan qui a su rebondir
quand à lui est avec nous ce soir pour
tout nous dire de cette fois l'histoire
c'est avec no mercy fabrice bonsoir
seulement je suis très heureux de voir
est fabrice beaux gosses un frère
fabrice est née à paris
robert lui était née à new york mais
sans argent il est né à munich va c'est
en allemagne que tout va commencer à
munich
voila voila ouais c'est en allemagne
tout a commencé à munich à la fête de
l'achoura
vous partez vivre à munich et c'est là
que vous rencontrez donc robert et vous
décidé de créer un groupe de musique ça
s'appelle umpire bizarre c'était le
début et c'était le projet à robert
ouais on s'est rencontrés mais ferrand
viens viens je vois moi quand je fais ok
cool mais alors vous avez créé un
premier single est en 88 vous allez
devenir milli vanilli milli vanilli que
tout le monde connaît ah oui c'est un
truc du milli vanilli c'est un
producteur qui vous repère qui a une
idée pour vous vous étiez parfait pour
incarner un groupe mais pas pour chanter
selon lui puisque vous chantez comme une
merde
[Rires]
il nous a découverts à cause de ce
musicien avec qui il travaillait aussi
fait qu'on se trouve au studio bombay on
a cru que c'était un truc été réglo mais
en fait c'était pas ça il avait il avait
en plus avec boney m c'était la voix
moment bien sûr mars et elle savait pas
chanter non plus mais je t'ai des poids
lui
et donc vous n'avez vous chantez pas de
ouf je chante moi je peux te donner un
petit exemple
kane ou échouent à la vieux de dix
millions d'exemplaires ça se casse
numéro en allemagne en espagne en
australie numéro de la danse et surtout
aux états unis succès énorme et à quel
moment vous comprenez que vous jouer un
jeu dangereux parce que vous chantez
jamais en fait non mais si c'est passé
en fait c'est que bon quand on est
arrivé avec frank farian
et nous à fait ok voilà un contrat et
producteurs font du tort il était en
allemand y'avait pas l'avocat y avait
pas de manager d'accord après ça nous a
fait voilà l'argent
la petite avance et puis quand à vos
insultes après chaque mois fait on on a
besoin de thunes ok ok mais quand il
était temps d'arriver au studio de
chantier l'a fait non vous chantez pas
je suis en quoi bon se casse
ab donc l'argent bah oui quand même fort
payé comment faire donc vous étiez pas
comment qu'est-ce qui chante à votre
place c'était john davis champions
j'aimerais que tu sont à votre pasqua
voilà mais même avec eux il n'aura pas
dit qu'ils allaient faire ça adacore ya
joué tulmont été séparés mais alors ils
ont tous peur en fait peut il leur
faisait croire qu'ils allaient chanter
mais qu'on allait les bois et vous allez
pouvoir vous chantez énorme
c'est énorme cette histoire d'hommes et
c'est incroyable 1 et enfin c'est à
l'architecte du tout ça le met donc vous
n'avez jamais chanté un studio vous
n'avez jamais enregistrés ça et nous
allons même pas laisser essayé une fois
alors on n'était pas intéressé par ça
c'était ok je veux les voir les bêtes
filon l'image c'est sa voix si fou mais
je vais faire peut-être ça avec vous du
playback
alors c'était le playback ça c'est un
exercice difficile parce que vous avez
fait du playback taux d'admis au oui
seulement avec vivendi avant ça j'étais
un chanteur à 6h10 ont chanté avec des
musiciens qui travaillent avec lui c'est
la raison pour laquelle on n'a fait que
bon c'était comme j'ai dit régler au
carré au total vous allez vendre près de
30 millions de dinars en clignant de
nice sans jamais avoir enregistré en
studio
ils sont dix années juste au-dessus dû
regarder les autres et est donc non non
on les a jamais vient au studio à vous
laisser nous asseoir et oui oui non déjà
mal an dont studio mais on était aussi
mais quand on est hélas en a eu pas là
d'accord pourquoi être allé au studio
pourquoi pour faire des photos
non non non pas ça parce qu'on devait le
voir d'accord allez on ne veut organiser
des trucs voilà alors et donc c'est
complètement c'est vrai vous classer
numéro un aux états unis avec girl you
know it's you
[Musique]
voilà donc girl une autre chose tu sais
que c'est vrai tu sais que c'est vrai et
vous recevez en 90 c'est la consécration
vous obtenez un grammy award de la
meilleure révélation c'est comme une
victoire de la musique aux etats-unis
c'est énorme et c'est énorme c'est tout
simplement la plus grande des
récompenses
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous nous rejoignez cette histoire et
fois lancé une exclusivité pour touche
pas à mon poste en direct voit tous les
téléspectateurs sont folie disent que
c'est que cette histoire
le problème c'est qu'avec le succès la
supercherie prend des proportions
énormes
vous montez au monde entier ce que vous
dites à tout le monde que vous chantez
vous bon en fait ce qu'on a fait c'est
que vont avec le premier single on
voulait chanter à cause de la dette
on a compté à travailler vers son
voulait chanter usa fait n'en voulait
pas chanter non c'est fait séduire mais
qu'en fait par cette vie de rock star a
bien sûr est clair les femmes les boîtes
et ya pas eu la légion jours qui vous a
dit faudra chanter en direct jamais non
maintenant parce qu'au début en europe y
avait pas ça non d'accord et passages
étaient tous les actes du monde chantait
en playback et il ya aussi une chose que
c'était quelque chose qui était très
commun dans le thread la musique avant
parce que les européens aient chanté il
sentait pas en anglais qui fait d'aller
chercher des gens qui chantaient en
anglais de londres et puis mettez des
visages et puis ce qui fait qu'il ya
plein d'exemples comme ça mais ça ne
savait pas il ya la supercherie ne va
pas durer éternellement puisque la
première grosse alerte était déjà arrivé
le 21 juillet 89 en plein concert aux
états unis la bande son sur laquelle
vous faites semblant de chanter van gogh
et aboriginal mais hélas hélas ça ça a
été journée c'est un reportage et ils
ont fait ça comme ça mais en fait ça a
buggé on est parti on est revenue
regardez on regarde et on a l'image de
turner
et ça ça c'est un montage
c'est un montage et c'est en fait votre
producteur qui va vous trahir
oui vous souhaitiez être les vrais
chanteurs de votre nouvel album souvenir
ophuls vous engueuler avec lui et je
vais finalement convoqué la presse pour
tout leur dire vous allez leur dire que
vous êtes kick-ass et voilà que vous ne
chantier jamais voilà mais la raison
pour laquelle il a fait ça c'est parce
qu'on était en transition
manas les travées avec d'autres
producteurs avec d'autres maisons dit ce
qui fait qu'il a fait moi je vais
arrêter tout ça ben voilà ça qu'on
n'avait pas continué la même chose sur
quoi alors vous devenez la risée de tout
le milieu musical
là c'est la descente aux enfers là ça a
été dur comme un vrai ce que bon en plus
mon partenaire s'il a pris tellement mal
qu'il en est mort il est mort dakar
c'est assez incroyable parce que bon les
jokes les blagues à un moment ou un
autre
les gens doivent ils réalisent pas que
bon on est content parce que ça blesse
ça plait ça blesse à 13 c'est vrai et ce
qui fait que bon moi j'ai pris un autre
chemin parce qu'ils vont j'adorais la
musique ma passion c'est devenir un
signe au sein du ce est ce que je fais
que j'ai jamais arrêter de faire la
musique de dj aussi je produis et puis
bon ben il ya beaucoup de choses qui
vont arriver là en fait le film qui est
en prônant le fils de notre histoire
le documentaire le livre a ouai mais
ccrvs et non mais alors été desserrée
aussi qui va rapporter près de 10
millions de dollars au groupe donc à
bout 2 5 millions de dollars chacun non
combien alors ça rapporte qu'à la maison
disque aux états unis 250 millions de
dollars us à 250 millions de dollars ça
rapporte un label à la maison de disques
aux etats-unis
et vous comment ça vous a rapporté bon
c'est ça on va en parler dans le livre
est dans le film on s'est fait arnaquer
vraiment vraiment fier à la fin on était
les petits maillons mais dans la presse
ils ont fait comme si on avait tout
organisé alors que pressé c'est ridicule
parce qu'il y avait des maisons disent
qu'ils avaient 10 millions de dollars en
madiun voilà pour les deux c'est ce
qu'on m'a dit besson vous auriez 5%
c'est énorme c'est énorme et vous auriez
pu gagner beaucoup plus willy bernard
cyril alors moi l'époque les avait reçus
d'un à une et à vous le samedi
après-midi sur terre ouais ok
non pas parce que voici que voilà le nom
mesic à télécharger s'arrêter il ya 50
ans et donc j'ai jamais reçu c'était
vague d'hystérie mais incroyable c'était
un trou devant le studio ont décidé non
plus si tu avais la complicité des
médias aussi parce que justement nous on
savait on savait pas tous à l'époque en
revanche vous chantiez comme doute la
plupart des artistes en playback cessa
pas rendu compte voilà c'est ce qui
compte
aujourd'hui je vous sens heureux quand
même ça vous êtes sorti richard est
content et que j'ai des enfants sachent
un seul hanche et ma femme tu es ça va
très bien super content parce que je
fais ce que je veux voilà créativement
registre avec précise musique on va
sortir un album collaborations avec des
artistes notoires la corde boucherie
d'angleterre de france aussi des
collaborations je travaille avec
fabienne carat on va faire un travail
qu'elle au studio mais on a décidé faire
un petit truc où je suis dans le trac
aussi avec elle fabienne super cool et
ce qui fait qu'avec précise musique la
musique la renaissance musicale va
prendre place de la france est ben merci
à l'état
merci d'avoir été avec nous l'histoire
incroyable voilà merci nous l'avoir
raconté s'arrête l'objet d'un film
voulait prochainement merci